[Music]
says we're going live says we're live
we are live and hello everyone and
welcome to round table with the stream
team and this is where we talked to
amazing guests about the how they
decided to become content creators and
what they did where they became what
they've kind of grown into now so
tonight we have brought a very good
friend of mine who happened to be
someone that we met in PAX East last
year of myself and MJ actually believe
it or not he was the other man he was
the man behind the camera over there mr.
Dan OH - sir
hello how are you I'm doing well I'm
doing doing quite well it's it's been a
spin it's love day but it's it's not bad
yes well thank you very much for coming
we I know that it's today's your day off
so I appreciate you taking it you know
this hour to come hang out with us and
talk and chat about about everything
content creation and and you know some
games and you know just some fun stuff
in general so I appreciate you coming
thank you well thanks for thanks for
having me man
thank you very much and we have our
other panelists today we have our our
good old buddy MJ is a boss what's going
on in J how are you I'm doing good how
about yourself I'm - I'm doing well and
and once again you did not use your
catchphrase what's poppin that is
thinking got in the chat oh he missed it
I'm sorry you gotta save it for this
show that's it for the show but I'll do
it at the end okay thanks
and.and you heard you know our amazing
female co-panelist l-boogie Oh - oh wait
how are you Elle
I am good how are you doing on this like
horrible Monday other than it being
Monday and having to wake up and go to
work Graeme's a good Monday it's like
the day you got to get up and you just
like first day working you gotta go you
gotta go
and then for me it's Thursday and
Thursday is my other day of the week
that I just like yes I'm just like
and it's just painful and then once I
get there I'm good but so well we're on
time so that I was like cool that let's
hope that sets the tone for the weekend
you know we're like not running late yes
yes I agree I agree
so and thank you thank you again for for
joining us so so we we are here I'm
sorry I cut you off I apologize so -
good sir so yeah why don't you why don't
you give us your your you know your
story of becoming a content creator and
how you kind of journey to become what
you're doing right now and and kind of
how you're growing once you go ahead and
give us that that story oh man um where
I start so way way way that's like it
legitimately was a long time ago
when I just started like breaking things
apart and kind of talking about them in
front of people so back when a back
route the end of high school middle
beginning of college which was like 10
years ago - 11 years ago Jesus
I was playing call of duty
professionally and started getting to
like the eSports before eSports were
called eSports we did not call them
eSports back then that's how old I am so
we started playing a bunch of
tournaments and a bunch of like you know
traveling up and down the west coast and
a lot of these things based on what like
you did back in the day it was climbing
ladders like MLG before MLG was MLG they
would call them game battles it before
MLG bought them up and then they became
their own thing so I started playing
that and that kind of brought me into a
whole different world about
entertainment and what it meant to be
doing stuff in front of people via video
games because you know that I'd play
sports and stuff like that so we
understand like what sports are sports
are very much a known thing and a very
popular thing at that point still and
then and then we started to learn about
what eSports were we just called it
competitive gaming at that point and
then that turned into a couple of guide
companies actually coming to our team
that I was mainly with for
long time and asked us to like be a part
of a strategy guide writing crew so we
had been doing something for like so
that our our clan leader was was as a is
a graphic artist so he like would make
old maps based on like so come when we
were playing SOCOM and then we
eventually moved him to a Call of Duty
and there's just like well do you feel
like making a thing for us and putting
it in a book and maybe consulting on
some of the strategy and we're like okay
we'll do that so they did that for a
couple books and then it happened to
happen to come about that I was I was a
writer and I was studying to be a writer
so they're like okay we want to go
actually like we'll just send you to go
do something like this and see what they
come out with and then then we did that
and I started getting into strategy
guide writing and and that turned into
getting a little bit deeper and a little
bit deeper into what it meant to do like
entertainment inside the video game
world and then at one point throughout
college I started a radio station
started being on the radio and talking
about metal music and video games and
all kind of stuff like that and then
that turned those two things combined
and they're like hey do you want to run
our twitch channel it's like um no I
have no idea what I'm doing there but
I'll try it
we're figuring out yeah so they're like
okay we're gonna start we're gonna start
like a couple month plan to figure that
out I was like okay maybe it might as
well start my own channel and that's
when and it's one kind of if I started
the day Natasha name because my
competitive name was sabotage and my
name is Dan so I was like okay let's
just be creative and jam them two
together because that's how it's our
creativity works people so slam together
you get a sandwich pretty much yeah and
then so so I did that and started to
kind of worked with somebody else to
build a community to start raising money
for extra life back when we started that
was like our reason for like starting
and in general and I was like well that
happens to be that that's how it sounds
like an awesome plan and I gotta get I
gotta get about what Twitch's anyway so
let's put those two together and and
then yeah that sort of started my
channel I started streaming Borderlands
2 no Borderlands the pre-sequel
with no mic with no camera I just
started streaming it and typing in chat
and and hanging out with like that three
or four people that would come by and
watch and and then and then it sort of
went from there I started that they
started like putting together a camera
putting all my taking all my audio
equipment out from renting it out from
from a radio station and using that for
a little bit and then started putting
together the couple things there and I
started learning about I was I was you
know the the reason I was in college was
for media and film and audio and and
stuff like that and writing more than
anything because it was communication so
I started to like put together a show
and start to put together a lot of the
hardware that went with it I sort of
understood it already so it was a nice
big boost into that so basically all the
things started to combine and then I
just I just started streaming I I mean
as an author and as an in school and
being able to kind of run my own
schedule I was just able to just start
streaming I wasn't streaming very long
every day but I was streaming like every
day and people started coming in started
hanging out I started meet a lot of cool
people and I started meeting streamers
basically immediately because I had
already been going to stuff like III and
and and PACs and whatnot so I started
meeting people almost immediately and
then started making friends and then it
just kind of went from there and started
streaming and streaming and streaming
and then add the streaming world just
kind of grew up at that point so it's
been almost five years now of full-time
streaming and yeah that's where we are
today at the end of the the long and
short of it really the low mature who
was who was your first who's your first
streamer that you met and kind of
connected with well there was a small
group of them but it there was one that
kind of sparked it so I had been
following and watching Tiger Ryder for a
long time so I met him at e3 who was
there with scarfy know back then she was
obese Janka now it's monkey ism and and
death death sculpt mm-hmm I think
they're in Santa
and Santa's so there was like a bunch of
us we all went to lunch started like you
know kicking it off and stuff like that
and just kind of set it off from there
cuz he had known me from his chat and he
had known that I screamed and stuff like
that so we started like just kind of
hanging out and never really nothing
ever really like came up as far as like
how that went and and then it was just
like okay cool let's like this is
awesome you guys are fantastic and you
seem pretty nice and I was just like hey
well let's I'll see you later right
after lunch after lunch is over because
he they were all hanging out and was
like Oh see you later right was it and
then he asked me like what are you doing
tonight
so well that just kind of chilling with
I had a lot of my co-workers there so it
was we're just like probably gonna get I
don't know if dinner or something like
that not really too much
he's like glad we're going to this
twitch party and I know that you just
started streaming like a couple months
ago so like you want to come I was like
sure and I they brought me in and and we
hung out that's where I met a bunch of
staff members that I'm still friends
with too today and and it turned out
that I got to meet a couple cool people
there too gummy bear who I'm still
really good friends with today I've met
it there for the first time and we ended
up hitting it off and and it just kind
of everything kind of blossomed into
something much bigger because back then
it wasn't a huge deal to be going to
like this twitch party it was like one
of the first twitch parties that ever
existed it was III 2014 or 15 or
whatever now it's like nobody it'll go
to the twitch party because it's too
packed because there's too many people
back then it was like no we need people
in here yeah so so they they we just
kind of all hung out there and had a
good time so yeah that was like some of
my first friends here on Twitch but it's
it's just grown since then I'm still
friends with Tiger Ryder still friends
with I actually everybody in that group
I don't talk to talk to everybody as
nearly as much but it is uh they're
there and there's we still hang out and
they're still good people and you know
never never we're gonna give up those
friendships cuz they're some of the best
you'll have ever known and yeah it's
just kind of gone from there now these
people they also they work for it
directly for twitch some of them none of
those people do but I did meet some
people they're like
who I guess one of the only ones I knew
from twitch at that point was who would
it have been siren I guess siren was the
event coordinator for like parties and
stuff at that point now she now she's
one of the assistants for running
twitchcon they met siren and she's the
one that helped me get into the party
and get into like the stuff and whatever
and then and then I found out that that
she lived in she she lived in which is
from San Diego obviously living in San
Francisco and then when we finally like
moved there and did a bunch of extra
life stuff together it was just like oh
we're just you know hanging out it's
cool so we kind of hit it off there yeah
that's pretty cool that's cool
now dude there's one thing you kind of
like skimmed over was the the some of
the stuff that we kind of spoke about
before when we were on the iron alloys
podcast is you did the competitive csgo
stuff correct I did a little bit csgo my
main gig was Call of Duty oh yeah and
then after a while you kind of evolved
and did other things and we you say you
did the right the premium game writing
books correct
it was Prima or I worked yeah so some of
the first the first company ever worked
with us piggyback and then Brady games
and then prima games and then eventually
Brady games and prima games became one
company Prima
yeah yeah now I'm gonna shameless plug
for you I happen to have this book right
here so I figured I give you that plug
it's on Amazon if you if you would like
it that's a whole different that's a
whole different thing - yeah yes but
like I myself I went I actually read it
and I went through it and I thought it
was pretty interesting and it kind of
gives you know a little bit of a
background thought process of how some
of the thoughts and and how some of the
things you wouldn't imagine to make a
difference in your streaming life to end
up kind of helping you to to grow and to
build that community which which is it
was just pretty is pretty nice and LGD
do you have any questions for for mr.
Danno
while we're going it's all so I'm not
sick cuz I'll sit here and I'll be data
while talking all day because we were
literally we were talking for almost 45
minutes before the before the show
started but uh did you have anything you
were thinking of I got one oh you got
won't go ahead I'm Jack yeah so when she
first started streaming what system are
we on PC like you said you were playing
Borderlands yeah yeah I was on PC
because I didn't have any of the capture
technology yet it was back then it was
still super expensive like yeah to get
one of the how Pasha's was like 300
bucks which I I had that I had that
stuff but I didn't want to use it
because it was like specifically for for
work and guide writing and stuff at that
point but but yeah it was mostly just PC
stuff and then but I came from I came
from when I was playing call of duty I
was on xbox so that was like the main
gig there and then eventually it was
mostly all PC because I was just the
easiest thing to do at that point which
Call of Duty I competed in one in two
and for the good ones all the infinity
warrant reward ones yeah all the all
that I should say the respawn ones
because most the people that worked on
those games don't work for Infinity Ward
anymore
that's why it's so good he responded the
team at respawn has never made a bad
game in my opinion all the way from Call
of Duty 1 and this high praise so you
got Call of Duty 1 Call of Duty 2 Call
of Duty 4 cuz I didn't do they didn't do
3 and then most a team went on to make a
respawn which made titanfall titanfall 2
Star Wars Jedi fallen order and apex
legends and all of those are bangers
right angry please tell me a beta P even
if you have to lower the difficulty I
would recommend beating it it's just I
haven't
I don't know I just get cool back into
like multiplayer I'm like it's worth it
it's not that long I would say it's
worth just going through it I think I'm
probably got like an hour left like
maybe two hours left like I just gotta
just buckle down and just do it cuz it's
just greed I just gotta do it
it's just escape from tarkov it's just
like pulls me I wanted to be better I
want to do better
so if you guys I'm sorry I see a couple
of people talking to chat about the
audio and the video and stuff I actually
got a new streaming system here so I
apologize if it's a little off but just
just know that your input is helpful so
going back to coming back to Dan so when
you when you decided to go vol 2 the
whole entire streaming realm if you will
so you kind of you kind of just evolved
because you were is already in that
competitive space so like oh like your
family kind of knew what you kind of did
you kind of they were okay with you go
into that streaming space and talking
about that type of stuff um they didn't
really have any idea cuz like I was
working I was working for so while I was
while I was when I first started it like
cuz I was a freelancer right so I never
really had a real job at prima games
right I was just a freelancer basically
got whatever jobs they decided to give
me so there's nothing guaranteed there
so I for a long time I never left my job
my full-time job before that so I had a
full-time job was working about 50 hours
a week going to school three to four
days a week depending on the semester
and then in between that streaming for
like three days after work or three yeah
three days a week about three hours I
know sorry everyday three hours a day
after work and just kind of resting it
that way and then when there was a job I
actually wouldn't stream for a while so
I would I would you know sort of try to
figure out what I'm doing there and
sometimes there was travel going on
sometimes I had to lie to my job and say
I'm sick when I cuz they wouldn't give
me the time off I hated that job with a
passion
I did it I did that for four years
Wallace it was I'm not gonna say who it
was but it was it was a food product
company I would say like they did and
basically what I did and you probably
figured out if you if you ever worked in
a grocery store or something like this
what I would do is I would go to grocery
stores and I would basically stock our
shelves whatever our product was I would
stock our shelves but that also meant
like we'd have to build like the huge
displays that you see in the stores you
have to like truck out you know
thousands of pounds of product every
single day and it was just like it was
killing me
it was legitimately like physically and
everything killing me because like I was
I was in shape but I wasn't like nearly
as strong as I am today and it just
became it was exhausting working like 12
to 13 to 14 hours a day and then still
coming home and trying to stream it was
it was rough and and the pay was while
it paid my bills and paid my rent and
stuff like that well seriously didn't
seem that like that much even after all
the hot of the holiday pay and overtime
and even being in a union it was it was
hell but it definitely taught me I'd
worked several retail jobs before that
too but it definitely taught me what it
what it was like to do something you
don't want to do for so long and gave me
kind of the drive to go do something
else but but it was still scary because
you could never quit it right everything
else I was doing was never gonna pay the
bills but but I was jumping on something
that was a little bit risky and stuff
like that so to go back and answer your
question my parents did really my family
never really knew and they liked even
today they know what I do but they don't
really understand but they never really
knew what I was doing because it was
sort of this it was just a side thing
and when I was doing like books and
stuff like that every now and then I did
you know there'd be like a call of duty
or something that would come out and my
mom would go buy one of the books and
she'd give it to my little brother and
like when I came home for Christmas or
something like that I would sign it for
her and stuff like that so it they she
they very much appreciated that I was
doing something in
some sort of spotlight but they had
really had no idea what it was so they
were as probably as supportive as they
could be without knowing anything really
like not because not because they just
not because I kept a secret they just I
knew they wouldn't understand and when I
would try to explain it they still
didn't understand so they just kind of
went on that way yeah it seems like
that's that's what the the global
thought process is with a lot of parents
from from a lot of people that we've
spoken to there their parents or family
or anyone when you talk to them about
you know wanting to stream or what you
do is streaming or content creation if
you will it's like they don't understand
fully understand what it is so I kind of
feel like it's more of a generational
thing like we understand it and you know
when we have kids they'll understand it
because what like will understand for
them but like right now like my parents
I told them I'm like 9 o'clock please
don't open the door don't ask me
questions don't call me because you
don't understand how your computer works
I have to do I have to do this podcast
with friends of mine so let like I have
to kind of inform them of those things
but they're kind of just like what is a
podcast and I'm like I downloaded it for
my parents for my mom and my mom's like
I don't even know how to play this and
listen to it I was like okay mom it's
okay it's it's in layers you know you
can you can talk about this in many
layers like my stepdad he pretty much he
gets it like he showed up in my channel
many times he he knows what's going on
he's there too he's usually there to
troll me too cuz he's just that kind of
guy
he's like yeah you know who's this guy
on the screen I this isn't the channel I
flip to stuff like that yeah you know
he'll sit there and troll me he just he
just kind of understands it that way my
mom just kind of gets the the spillover
of whatever he tells but my dad has
asked basically every holiday what it to
explain to him what it is cuz he knows
what it is but he doesn't really get it
so I've explained to him dozens
let us go again missiles dropping frames
salsas are live still dropping packets I
don't know what to say or do
did you do see a comeback in jr. now
yeah you seen it come back I don't think
I can hear it really anything
wait now it's loading I said it's the
Martha now it's loading second I
switched but now it's loading I don't
know why it's just randomly dropping up
now I got an ad it's the ads are working
perfectly
oh that's that's you know super laggy
yeah you wait
it's like lagging